لكن مطارات اوروبيه جلال كانت قد تاثرت
بالعطله الذي اصاب نظام الملاحه الامريكيه
منها مطار هيبرو في العاصمه البريطانيه
لندن الذي يتابعوا صورا منه الان كما كانت
ايضا وتبعنا مع نور الدين بوزيان من باريس
قبل قليل ااه سلطات الطيران في فرنسا قد
اعلنت تاثرا رحلاتها بنفس العقل ايضا
ينطلق منها العديد من الطائرات المتوجهه
الى الساحل الشرقي في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه لاسيه الى جي اف كي في نيويورك
او جلس في واشنطن همم اذا مره اخرى الى
باريس الجزيره نور الدين بوزيان يعود
وينضم الينا نور الدين اذا يبدو بان
الرحلات المغادره من باريس لم تتاثر صحيح
هناك الان جلال انفراج واضح بدليل ان هذا
المثال الطائره الفرنسيه التي تحمل رقم
3625 اييي كان مقررا تقلع الساعه الثانيه
بتوقيت باريس والدقيقه ال 27 تاخرت فقط
7/10 دقيقه مع ذلك ان البلاغه الذي ورد من
الولايات المتحده بان هناك بدايه معالجه
هذه المشكله او تكون قد حلت بنسبه كبيره
بدا تنعكس ايجابا على الرحلات المبرمجه من
باريس باتجاه الضفه الاخرى من الحلف
الاطلسي اذكره بجلال بان اليوم في 46 رحله
بين باريس ومطار جي اف كي في نيويورك طبعا
بها الشركات او ما يسمى الرحلات التجاريه
المشتركه من بين هذه الرحلات رحله الثامنه
ونصف صباحا اقلعت في وقتها رحله مثلا
فيرجن اطلنتيك كانت مقرره التاسعه و 37
لكنها تاخرت ساعتين
الطائره الفرنسيه التي تلتها تاخرت بساعه
معنى ذلك الوتيره كانت بطيئه الان قد يسال
همم المشاهدون كيف اقلعت وهناك مشكله في
الولايات المتحده ببساطه تعرف جيدا جلال
كما تعرف مريم بان رحله تستغرق ما بين
باريس ومطار جيفكي اذا كانت الرياح مناسبه
للطائره ست ساعات ونصف او سبعه معنى ذلك
عندما اقلعت الطائره من باريس كان مح-
يعني مخططا لها ان في نصف الطريق يكون قد
حل المشكل التقني في الولايات المتحده لكن
الاهم من كل ذلك نفت لنا المتحدثه باسم
مطار شلدغو قبل نصف ساعه في اتصال هاتفي
ان تكون او يكون هذا المطار قد اصدر بيان
يقول فيه بان جميع الرحلات المتجهه من
باريس الى الولايات المتحده هي مؤجله الى
الى موعد غير معلن هذا تكذيب واضح وهذا
يؤكد همم هذا التدريب يؤكد بان رحله بدات
الان تستانف في مواعيدها هو الرحله
الفرنسيه المقرره الساعه الرابعه والنصف
بتوقيت باريس سا مسجله الان على الموقع
الرسمي لمطار شاندو جول انها ستقلع في
وقتها وحتى ان المسافرين سجلوا انفسهم
ودفعوا بحقائبهم باتجاه الطائره جلال
ومريم